[Música]
como muchos de nosotros cuando era chico
quería tener superpoderes anticipando lo
que después le harían tantos libros y
verían tantas películas soñaba con curar
y con tener poderes mágicos para
construir cosas soñaba con defender
pequeñas aldeas de terribles invasores
después el tiempo nos da un baño de
realidad parece el subte y no tenéis la
varita mágica de harry potter es
imperioso invadir que que me has aldeas
y no tenés la posición de panoramix para
defenderlas pero algo de esa vocación de
chico quedó en mí y casi sin darme
cuenta toda la vida me dediqué a mirar y
a tratar de entender cómo funcionan esos
superpoderes no son mi imaginación sino
en el mundo real
hoy quiero compartir con ustedes seis
ideas para desarrollar uno de los
principales superpoderes tal vez el más
importante en esta situación que toca
vivir
que es el superpoder de pensar mejor
obviamente hay muchos más superpoderes y
muchas más herramientas para pensar
mejor pero hoy me quiero enfocar en las
que creo que son menos conocidas
porque les voy a contar no son ideas
mías las aprendí de otros y esta es tal
vez la principal de todas las ideas algo
así como la idea cero de esto que les
voy a contar que somos capaces de
aprender y que nuestra capacidad de
pensar no viene nada ni está fija sino
que puede ser desarrollada poblando
nuestra mente con ideas potentes y
practicando entonces ahí vamos
descuentos 6 ideas que aprendí de otros
para pensar mejor
la primera imagínense que entran en un
gimnasio
miran pesas en el piso aparatos vacíos
bicicletas fijas se dan media vuelta se
van al bar tienen un café con leche con
3 les algunas de manteca y será como no
funciona sino nuestro cuerpo no mejora
con esto
bueno compensar pasa lo mismo no cuenta
poder pensar lo que cuenta es pensar
tenemos que practicar pensar desarrollar
en nosotros el hábito de pensar y darnos
el tiempo para pensar la inteligencia no
es algo que se tiene o no se tiene es
algo que se usa o no se usa
la segunda
dice el dicho quien sólo ve un martillo
que sólo tiene un martillo de todos los
problemas como un clavo
pero si tenemos que sacar un tornillo no
nos sirve un martillo ni hacer de cuenta
que es un clavo si tenemos un tornillo
necesitamos un destornillador y si
necesitamos cortar algo necesitamos un
serrucho tener una caja de herramientas
con más herramientas nos permite hacer
más cosas solucionar más problemas y las
herramientas de la mente se llaman
modelos mentales si solo tenemos un
modelo mental
vamos a pensar todos los problemas con
ese modelo como si tratáramos de sacar
un tornillo con un serrucho si tenemos
muchos modelos mentales nuestra mente es
mucho más potente pero adónde se
encuentran esos modelos mentales de
donde los sacamos cuando se encuentran
en distintas disciplinas en distintos
lugares y en distintos tiempos por
ejemplo hay modelos mentales
interesantes en la física y la biología
en la ingeniería en la psicología y
también hay modelos mentales distintos
en japon en tanzania y en argentina- en
modelos mentales en el antiguo egipto
hace 3000 años antes de cristo en la
edad media
para pensar mejor tenemos que ampliar la
caja de herramientas de nuestra cabeza
si no todos los problemas nos van a
aparecer un clavo
la tercera
hace poco estaba en el club y en la mesa
de al lado un hombre le decía a sus
amigos que le había dicho de todo el
profesor de fútbol de su hijo adelante
de su hijo y de sus compañeros por un
error que el profesor había cometido
el hombre tenía razón en todo lo que le
decía a sus amigos lo que le había dicho
al profesor
pero no se daba cuenta de que al decirle
esto estaba generando un mal mucho mayor
en su hijo estaba dejándolo como un
tonto delante de sus amigos y estaba
deslegitimando al profesor a delante de
todos los chicos que tenían que aprender
de él
muchas veces no nos damos cuenta de que
estar enfocados en ganar en una escala
nos hace tener éxito en esa escala y sin
saberlo hacemos cosas que nos hacen
perder en otra escala más importante
ganar una discusión y perder una amistad
por ejemplo ganar plata y tardo en
libertad o ganar libertad y perder amor
cuando actuamos pensemos en qué escalas
impacta lo que vamos a hacer y cuál es
la escala más importante en la que
tenemos que pensar cómo actuar
la cuarta
y el principito nos enseñó que lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos
es a través de los ojos de los sentidos
donde generamos nuestras impresiones y
las impresiones nos generan emociones y
las emociones nos hacen actuar por
ejemplo ahora en la pandemia nos
llegaban muchos datos de la situación de
china pero esos datos nos generaban
impresiones nos generaban emociones y
nos hacían que actuemos cuando empezaron
a llegar imágenes de italia un país que
sentimos más familiar y parecidos de
china esas impresiones y generan emoción
el miedo y el miedo general generó
acción que estemos todos ahora guardados
preventivamente lo que está muy bien
esta vez tuvimos la suerte de que el
miedo nos dio tiempo porque le pasó a
alguien parecido antes que nosotros pero
muchas veces es importante actuar cuando
todavía no vemos y sentimos
la práctica de anticipar es lo que nos
distingue a la civilización moderna de
la prehistórica casares una cosa tenés
hambre casas tenés una recompensa
inmediata te comes lo que pasaste pero
cultivar es muy distinto haces el
esfuerzo ahora para algo que vas
aprovechar dentro de seis meses o un año
este es el pilar de casi todo lo que
tenemos
prevenir nos genera aplausos porque
estás evitando algo que nadie ve ni
siente pero salva vidas
desarrollamos la capacidad de actuar
antes de sentir es decir desarrollar
nuestra capacidad de anticipar es una de
las principales habilidades de pensar
bien pensemos un minuto que tenemos que
anticipar ahora que todavía nos sentimos
ni vemos
la quinta todos evaluamos las cosas de
acuerdo a nuestras expectativas si algo
malo dura tres meses si pensamos que iba
a durar seis meses estamos contentos si
algo malo dura tres meses y pensamos que
iba a durar un mes estamos tristes es el
mismo tiempo son tres meses pero lo
vivimos completamente distinto
si nos programamos para correr 10 km por
ejemplo al kilómetro 9 estamos exhaustos
si nos programamos para correr 20 al
kilómetro 9
estamos impecables
hacemos un culto de la resiliencia pero
la clave de la resiliencia es manejar
bien las expectativas la sexta y última
alguna vez les pasó que se encontraron
con un conocido en un lugar rarísimo
estás caminando por un pueblito en el
medio de la nada y un compañero de la
secundaria que no verías hacía 15 años
no puedes crear una casualidad lo
improbable que se encontraba en ese
lugar para encontrar a ese compañero en
ese lugar es algo totalmente improbable
pero como conocemos tanta gente es muy
probable encontrar a alguien en un lugar
muy improbable de hecho nos pasa todo el
tiempo
bueno con el resto de la vida es igual
hay tantas cosas improbables que es muy
probable que nos pase algo muy
improbable el problema es que nuestra
mente nos hace pensar que lo improbable
es imposible y no lo es
dice el dicho que los pronósticos dicen
mucho del pronosticador y poco del
futuro no sabemos lo que va a pasar ni
ahora ni tampoco en tiempos más normales
tenemos que aprender a convivir con la
incertidumbre
y a lo mejor la forma inteligente de
convivir cuando incertidumbre es dejar
siempre muchas puertas abiertas para
pensar sobre lo más probable y buscar
maneras de cuidarnos cuando sea posible
de cosas graves aunque sean muy
improbables
y si alguien alguna vez te pregunta por
qué tienes siempre el auto con el tanque
de nafta lleno contesta les que porque
una vez te encontraste en un pueblito
del otro lado del mundo por un compañero
de la secundaria que no veías hace 15
años
les decía al principio que la idea cero
de esta charla seguramente la más
importante es desarrollar nuestra
capacidad de aprender y aprender tiene
que ver con estar al acecho al acecho de
ideas que nos hagan cambiar de forma de
pensar y de personas con las que
cultivar esas ideas
podríamos de personas que enriquezcan
nuestra forma de pensar
no se trata de convencer a otros se
trata de cambiar nuestras propias ideas
en una entrevista a borges hace 40 años
el entrevistador le hizo una pregunta y
cuando a borges le contesto el
entrevistador le dijo eso mismo usted me
contestó a esa misma pregunta hace
cuatro años
borges se quedó callado lo miró y le
dijo le pido disculpas no he tenido
mucho tiempo de pensar en ese tema
durante estos cuatro años aprovechemos
este momento límite que nos toca vivir
para estar al acecho de nuevas ideas de
las nuevas ideas que están surgiendo y
estar siempre abiertos a cambiar nuestra
forma de pensar gracias
[Aplausos]